[Music]
i
present you
first off we need to change do we
jump in one two three
[Music]
you're older than i am though you should
be the one leading by example okay well
then i'll say
this was the first item of firewood
stuff fireworks
this is epic bringing it back can't
believe you're here
but there's one thing missing look what
is
it kind of fits the purpose now that
we're wearing masks yeah
but do we have to be a responsible luigi
all right this is item number two
extremely manly
bacon scented mustard smell it here
oh that's disgusting i can smell it
through the mask
it tastes like it smells like those
crisps oh i kind of want to eat it yeah
oh i smell it through
look at that mario i read that mario
what the
is gonna be so happy with this video
pizza pasta
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
all right item number three are you
impressed so far do you have to jump
again
sure what is this
i think you like this confetti high five
yes
[Applause]
i think that's spanish i got one too and
my son was like i don't think you need
two but i'm like
we gotta get dude this is the reason i
stopped doing sideways stuff online by
the way because
it makes such a mess and i just can't be
bothered
don't forget kids always recycle
be like luigi and he recycles every time
yes
why you
oh it says confetti high five i didn't
actually expect confetti to come out
okay all right we can try it again okay
just stick your thing in time wait
you didn't expect what i don't
[Music]
there you go oh my god i'm sorry am i
sanitizing the nation of ireland with
this
now
[Music]
here we go we gotta jump right
okay like hit it there okay three two
one huh
i'm doing a timing practice
okay okay okay you didn't see you can't
have the scene you're regular
oh no how are you gonna clean this up
it's all right they got vacuums
one two three oh my god
did you come out yeah did it yeah i
didn't
it's empty
this is the one this is the one really
fat one
top of the order
oh my god yes
oh i kind of wish it may
but yeah edit that
all right that was item though i had the
number three that was epic you like
it yeah i quite i think the theatrics of
it are a lot
less than the mess yeah they don't need
to know about that
item number four it's a puzzle so we
have to solve it as quick as possible
three two one
i'll show you it comes off a little
spider got your
i tricked you i'm sorry
oh that's the worst i've even seen this
online
do you have it it's so good
oh my god i'm sorry it's all covered
with dust
okay since i feel bad why don't you have
a snack
that's fine why don't you help us i'm
not gonna get electrocuted don't i
no it's pringles
did you like that
you like potatoes luigi yes very much
i really like the bacon smell i gotta
say what else
uh i don't know what this is
[Applause]
it feels like we went back in time a
little bit like costumes
yeah we're all about let's make it
okay well it has a pump that's a good
start i honestly cannot remember what i
bought
why do i have two of them as well what
is this
oh there's a ton of things oh i know
what this is
it's a game i like games okay so you
blow this up
it's a reindeer horns you put this on
your head
and then you have to toss the rings oh
the wings
luigi we look badass dude
super cool
do you think in 10 years we're going to
cringe at this video i hope so
i hope i'm not like this 10 years
imagine being 40 and going like not my
peeps back then
yeah go there yeah yeah
all right who goes first you
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
okay since i scared you before i feel
bad so i think you'll enjoy these
do you know what these are these oh
these are the ones that float on your
hair
yes whoa oh
and i got two so you can do it as well
hell yeah oh that feels good
whoa hell yeah we did this before
have we done this together yeah oh we
passed it to each other
oh i remember now it didn't look as
nice as this one though and it didn't
work as well
dude magic is real it kind of feels like
you know when water touches the
the yeah you know guys
really having an interactive experience
for people
you
oh that's so cool let's end the video
here
i don't care about the rest of it yeah i
kind of
want a pb size one it is
wow
wow that's so cool well they are cool
wait how about how do i flatten it
that's magic
shut up by your brain
shut
item number i don't know a whistle
here put these on all right ear
protection
okay actually i need them you can just
cover your rings
i keep thinking i'm going to get like
electrocuted by anything you give me
that does look like one of those hand
things yeah oh there's nothing in this
that was just in the plastic
so this is the world's loudest whistle
oh god uh
for personal protection when being heard
is a matter of life
and death okay i'll wear them we can
actually measure the decibel level on my
watch so let's see the decimal level in
here
jesus whoa
[Music]
116 116 damn that's loud
yeah that's even kind of loud enough my
ears closed
damn oh i don't like it
yeah stop listening to a jacksepticeye
video
the final item what is it
mario i'm tagging your skit luigi
[Music]
so this is the water what is it a toilet
paper going
i can't pull the truth are you scared
yeah oh
that's disgusting
[Applause]
better for you oh my god keeps getting
stuck
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you killed my mother oh
no yes yes i was saved
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i'm actually scared of you holding that
thanksgiving please put it down
well this has been five weird stuff
online say
say who's the best youtuber the best
youtuber i will say it
[Applause]
mario ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean